Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt Chaosradio.
Question authority.
Think for yourself.
Throughout human history, as our species has faced the frightening, terrorizing fact that we do not know who we are or where we're going in this ocean of chaos, it has been the authorities, the political, the religious, the educational authorities who attempted to comfort us by giving us a better life.
Also was wir jetzt von deiner Geschichte, René, und auch natürlich von der Geschichte von Martin, glaube ich, mitgenommen haben in dieser ersten Stunde der Sendung, ist, dass diese allgemein angenommen, mir kann ja nichts passieren, ich habe ja nichts gemacht, Annahme sehr blauäugig ist, weil im Zweifelsfall hast du einfach Pech, stehst auf der falschen Seite der Straße und bist auf irgendeinem Foto mit drauf. Wir wollen jetzt überhaupt keine Panik machen, aber es kann eben passieren.
Vielleicht kannst du ja auch nochmal sagen, was heißt das eigentlich für dich jetzt? Du weißt ja, okay, sie haben dein Telefon mal abgehört, aber wie fühlst du dich da eigentlich?
Na ja, es kam halt so plötzlich und zum Beispiel ich mache irgendwas. Ich telefoniere oder ich bin im Internet oder ich spazier draußen nur mit meiner Freundin. Man weiß nie, ob man beobachtet wird oder irgendwas anderes. Und dann fühlte ich mich immer so, eigentlich mein ganzes Leben lang fühle ich mich so beobachtet. Verstehen Sie?
Das heißt, du hast schon eine gewisse Paranoia?
Wenn ich mit meiner Frau schlafe oder mit meiner Freundin jetzt verlobte oder irgendwas, dann weiß ich nie, ob da vielleicht irgendwelche Wanzen im Zimmer sind. Also soweit gehen die wirklich. Ich hab das auch mal so, okay, im Büchner gelesen, aber wenn ich denke, dass sie mein Telefon abhören, dann können die auch andere Sachen machen. Und die Frage ist ja, was man dahinter, also hinterher macht, wenn das alles irgendwie so bei mir, wo ich unschuldig war, und die mir so viele Sachen versaut haben. Auch, meine Mutter dachte auch ganz falsch von mir. Sie dachte gleich, okay, Überfälle und meine Familie und so.
Und das ist halt scheiße, aber...
Ach ne, vielleicht solltest du jetzt in der akuten Situation den Rat von Sönke, unserem Rechtsanwalt, befolgen und nochmal sozusagen mit dem Anwalt sprechen, der dich da beraten hat und diesen bei der Staatsanwaltschaft fragen, ob du einen Brief haben kannst, in dem drin steht, dass du nichts gemacht hast, damit du wenigstens diese Ausbildung weitermachen kannst.
Aber das war das Problem, weil der war ein Pflichtverteidiger, also vom Staat her bezahlt. Und ich kann mir halt das nicht leisten, einen neuen Rechtsanwalt zu holen. Aber dieses Formular, wo da drauf stand, das kommt halt diese, nicht diese Anklageschrift, wie heißt das? Dieser, am Ende dieses, was rauskommt.
Das war für eine Einstellungsentscheidung und die Aufhebung des Haftbefehls.
Genau, genau.
Ja, genau, das zeige ich dann halt so. Aber ich war halt selber erst mal durcheinander. Ich kam aus dem Knasthaus, ich meinte, okay, ich brauche das erst mal ein bisschen Ruhe und so. Und ich musste mich wieder, also wieder zu mir finden.
Krassige Geschichte, René. Danke, dass du dir erzählt hast.
Also ich habe eigentlich noch mehr erfahren, aber die stehe ich dann irgendwann. Wo kann man die, wo kann man euch erreichen?
Im Zweifelsfall kannst du eine Mail schicken an chaosradio at ccc.de. Danke für den Anruf. Tschüss René. Chaosradio am heutigen Mittwoch, dem 26. September, letzter Mittwoch vom Monat, das heißt der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast. Bei uns sind Frank und Constanze vom CCC weiterhin zu Gast. Ist Sönke Hilbrans, er ist Anwalt, Volker Eick ist auch da, er ist Politologe und Martin ist bei uns, der die Geschichte erzählt hat, wie er als unbescholtener Bürger, der von sich selbst sagt, wie wir auch so ekapärnisch gemacht, plötzlich das BKA im Haus, hatte die Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt haben. Und dazu machen wir heute auch diese Sendung, wie konkret funktioniert eigentlich diese Überwachung, von der so viele Leute reden dieser Tage, zu der es auch als Protest in der letzten Woche die große Demonstration in Berlin gab. Wie konkret funktioniert es eigentlich, wie sind eure Erfahrungen da in der Praxis und welche Fragen habt ihr dazu? Die könnt ihr stellen unter 0331 77 97 110. Wir werden nicht alle Fragen in jedem technischen Detail wirklich bis ins Letzte beantworten können, aber auch hier natürlich der Hinweis, Chaosradio at ccc.de, beziehungsweise ccc.de ist der Online-Kontakt, den ihr da gerne auch nutzen könnt. Frank Winkt.
Ja, also eine Frage, die mir noch so ein bisschen auf der Zunge brennt ist.
Hält Spuck's aus.
Diese Geschichte lief ja irgendwie offenbar sehr lange, also ein Jahr oder so was in der großen Klasse. Und du hast ja eine ganze Reihe von Überwachungsmaßnahmen aufgezählt.
Die Frage nur für Leute, die quasi es nicht sehen. Die Frage geht jetzt an Martin.
Genau, die da durchgeführt wurden. Haben die das alles auf einmal angemacht? Oder ist das jetzt so nach und nach irgendwie eskaliert worden? Oder wie muss man sich das dann tatsächlich praktisch vorstellen? Also ich meine, euer Wissen wird mir wahrscheinlich etwas begrenzt sein momentan noch.
Ja, das muss man Volker machen, glaube ich.
Man muss sich das, glaube ich, vorstellen wie so ein Schneeballsystem, die hier jetzt später zugeschaltet haben. Eine Person gerät aus irgendeinem Grund in Verdacht. Man guckt sich an, welche Leute kennt diese Person. Dann guckt man sich an, welche Leute die kennen. Und dann kommt man zu, um mal ein Beispiel zu nennen, der eine oder die andere hat das ja vielleicht mitgekriegt, als im Mai diesen Jahres 21 Leute beschuldigt worden sind, auch eine terroristische Vereinigung zu sein. Über 40 Wohnungen sind durchsucht worden, Buchläden und so weiter und so fort. Die haben dann irgendwann ihre Akten gekriegt, 33 Bände. Da stehen über 1000 Namen jetzt drin.
1000 Namen? Also für eine Gruppe, die beschuldigt wurde, hat sich dann natürlich gleich exponentiell erweitert.
Nicht mal eine Gruppe von diesen 21 Leuten kennt sich der große Teil überhaupt nicht. Die haben sich noch nie gesehen.
Also das ist quasi der statistische Effekt, den man natürlich hat, weil man ja jeder einzelne mit sehr vielen Menschen kommuniziert.
Ja, klar, Logo. Da kommt jetzt die Frage, die ich mir dann auch wieder stelle, als technischer Vollhorst. Du sagtest gerade, Volker, die Leute kennen sich untereinander gar nicht. Wenn bei einem geguckt wird, wer kennt den, dann guckt man den nicht. Stichwort MySpace-Profile. Ein Großteil von euch, die am Radio sitzen, werdet so ein Ding haben bzw. schon mal gehört haben, dass es sowas gibt. Ist es auch denkbar, dass man, wenn Eicke ins Visier kommt, dass man guckt, wer ist damit drauf? Und dann haben alle anderen Leute gleichzeitig auch eine Anfrage zu laufen? Ist sowas realistisch?
Also natürlich, wir haben es ja hier in dem Fall ohnehin gesehen, dass also Datenbestände von Firmen eben für die Ermittlung benutzt werden können.
Wir hatten ein Stichwort mit der Bahn zum Beispiel, mit Autovermietung.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Also klar, man kann ja die Unternehmen fragen. Wir haben aber eigentlich noch eine andere Diskussion, denn die Sicherheitspolitiker in Deutschland führen diesen, ich nenne es jetzt mal Web 2.0-Exhibitionismus oder auch die Tatsache, dass eben sehr viele Millionen Menschen in Deutschland eine Payback-Karte haben oder eine Happy-Digits-Karte, die führen diese Argumentation oft an und sagen sich, naja, die Menschen haben ja quasi freiwillig für diese privaten Datensammler ihre Daten rausgegeben. Also im Prinzip gibt es ja gar keinen Grund, warum nicht der Staat, dem man ja vertraut, diese Daten nicht eben auch haben sollte. Und da wird halt verkannt, dass man freiwillig privaten Firmen seine Daten gibt, aber dass die staatliche Form von Datensammler natürlich in keiner Weise freiwillig ist. Sondern man merkt sie ja teilweise nicht mehr und sie ist vor allen Dingen eben nicht freiwillig. Das heißt, man legt sich da nicht einen Account bei Myspace an, sondern natürlich werden die Daten hinter dem Rücken oder eben bei einem Verdacht gesammelt, ohne dass man da mitwirkt.
Und im Zweifelsfall hole ich mir irgendwo eine Paybackkarte, weil ich immer wieder frage werde, ob ich eine haben möchte, mit dem vorrangigen Ziel, irgendwann mal ein paar warme Socken oder eine Kaffeemaschine geschickt zu kriegen. Und dass es da irgendwo was Kleingedrucktes gibt, was ich mit unterschrieben habe, habe ich im Zweifelsfall in dem Moment einfach nicht gelesen und dann bin ich näse. Ja, letztes Jahr Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft, die Bedingung, dass man seine Personaldaten abgeben muss, damit man ein Ticket kriegt, mal ganz davon abgesehen, wie überhaupt die Zugangsbedingungen für Normalsterbliche zum Stadion waren. Wo die dann anfühlen, da ist es nicht kleingedruckt, das ist großgedruckt und wir haben euch ja zweimal gefragt, aber der Fakt bleibt, dass diese ganzen hochsensiblen Daten weiterverkauft werden und quasi die FIFA noch mal extra Geld mit den Daten dieser Leute macht, ohne dass sie irgendeinen Einfluss darauf haben, was mit diesen Daten dann passiert. Und wenn sie Glück haben, ist es nur Werbemüll in Briefkasten.
Ist denn dieses Aufblähen der Anzahl der Verdächtigen, verwenden die da auch Informationen aus dem Internet oder arbeiten die da nur auf der Basis von Telefondaten?
Nee, nee, noch ist das Publizieren in Deutschland nicht verboten. Das heißt, im Zuge des 21. Jahrhunderts, ich bin froh, dass ich das 19. Jahrhundert überwunden habe, publiziert man natürlich auch im Internet. Man publiziert natürlich mit wissenschaftlichen Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch international über E-Mail. Ich kann mich zum Beispiel gar nicht mehr daran erinnern, wie ich mit Kollegen früher in den USA oder Großbritannien kommuniziert habe. Das hat alles Ewigkeiten gedauert mit Briefen und so weiter und so fort. Natürlich macht man das. Man geht ja nicht davon aus, dass man da ein Problem mitkriegen könnte.
Habt ihr denn in diesem Zusammenhang Techniken verwendet, um eure Privatsphäre zu schützen, etwa E-Mail-Verschlüsselung?
In dem Moment kommt dann auch Sebastian ran, der wissen will, wie sicher heutzutage Verschlüsselungen sind. Sebastian, halt durch, du bist der nächste.
Jetzt deine Frage, Entschuldigung. Also, ich frage jetzt mal Martin, hast du deine E-Mails verschlüsselt?
Also, ich selber habe nie verschlüsselt, aber ich habe jetzt irgendwie nach dem Aktenstudium gemerkt, dass das Sachen sind, die das BKA total heiß machen. Also, eine große Begründung sozusagen für diese Ermittlungsverfahren ist neben der Übereinstimmung von irgendwelchen Wörtern das Stichwort konspiratives Verhalten. Und das definieren die auch nicht. Und dazu gehört alles, wenn irgendwie Leute versuchen, ihre Privatsphäre zu schützen.
Dann hast du möglicherweise sowas zu verbergen.
Also, die selber verschlüsseln oder verschlüsselte Chats benutzen oder, oder, oder, oder, anonyme, also den eigenen Namen nicht im E-Mail-Header oder sowas, da sind die total heiß drauf. Und das benutzen sie dann auch als Begründung nach dem Motto, wie können wir jetzt das Verfahren irgendwie weiterführen? Wir haben zwar sonst nichts gefunden, aber der verhält sich hier ganz konspirativ. Und da beißt sich natürlich auch die Katze im Schwanz. Einerseits wird da ein Riesenermittlungsapparat aufgebaut. Und wenn Leute dann aus dem kritischen Bewusstsein heraus überlegen, wie können wir hier ein bisschen sorgfältiger mit unseren eigenen Daten umgehen, dann ist das sofort Konspiration, Konspiration.
Okay, also Daten verschlüsseln war früher mal wichtig. Daten nicht verschlüsseln macht dich in dem Moment gleich auch mal, ich sage mal, verdächtig, in Anführungszeichen. Was soll man tun? Wir fragen mal Sebastian. Sebastian hat angerufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Und er kommt aus Berlin. Name, Sebastian. Verschlüsseln oder nicht verschlüsseln?
Also das ist jetzt eigentlich so meine große Frage, die ich so hatte. Also ganz generell wollte ich eigentlich auch nochmal nur appellieren, finde ich, dass die ganzen Leute eigentlich viel bewusster mit ihren Daten umgehen sollten. Also gerade auch jetzt, als diese Payback-Geschichte kam und so weiter, was dieses, weiß ich, Customer-Tracking oder dieses ganze Kaufverhalten und so weiter, wie das alles gelockt und verfolgt wird und so, dass sich die Leute eigentlich gar nicht bewusst sind, was sie davon sich preisgeben und so und eigentlich so viel mit sich machen lassen.
Alles für ein paar warme Socken.
Und immer diese Sache, ja, ich habe da nichts zu befürchten, sodass es ihnen eigentlich völlig egal ist, wer hier irgendwelche Daten hat und also das verstehe ich alles nicht.
Zum Thema, ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz auf den Anfang der Sendung hinweisen, zum Thema ich habe noch nichts zu befürchten, haben wir heute im Chaosradio gesagt Martin da, der gerade seine Geschichte erzählt hat und vor wenigen Minuten hat er auch René angerufen, der unter anderem Vorzeichen eine ähnliche Geschichte erzählt hat, wo er sagte, ich habe damit überhaupt nichts zu tun und plötzlich stand, plötzlich war er quasi mit dem Visier. So, deine Frage, Entschuldigung.
Ja, meine Frage ist eigentlich, wie, also sinnvoll ist es, also abgesehen davon, dass man vielleicht eher doch ins Visier gerät dann bei so Sachen, aber ich eigentlich permanent, wenn ich jemanden habe, der auch mit verschlüsselt bzw. also über GNU-PG meinen öffentlichen Schlüssel hat und so weiter und das alles macht, dann mache ich das auf jeden Fall. Ich bin auch dabei, weil ich eben auch überlegt habe, wie sichert man seine Daten, egal, ob ich da was verheimlichen will oder nicht. Ich will einfach nicht, dass irgendjemand das sieht und schon gar nicht der Staat. Und mir ist es eben nichts, den Rechner aus dem Netz zu holen. Also was hat man da für Alternativen, irgendwie muss man es ja immer, ich habe nicht Lust wegen jeder kleinen Sache irgendwie auf dem USB-Stick zu tun.
Sebastian, wo kommt dein Fragezeichen?
Mein Fragezeichen kommt, wie sicher ist es? Also man hört zwar immer...
Wie sicher ist die Verschlüsselung von...
Genau, also wenn ich mir auf Dateien zum Beispiel mit TrueCrypte, dann gibt es alle möglichen Verschlüsselungsverfahren, wenn ich die anwende, AIS, wie auch immer, alle Leute sagen, ach ja, BKA, die klacken das sowieso.
Also der...
Frage an den Chaos Computer Club, an Frank.
Ja, also die Sicherheit von unterschiedlichen Verschlüsselungsverfahren schwankt natürlich stark. Wenn man halbwegs vertrauenswürdige, gut belommnete Verschlüsselungsverfahren verwendet, kann man in der Regel sagen, ist die Sicherheit so gut wie dein Passwort? Das heißt also dein, also jetzt mal ausgehend von der Frage, du hast jetzt ganz angenommen, dass kein Online-Trojaner, keine Computer-Wanze auf deinem Computer ist, ist bei guten Verschlüsselungsverfahren die Sicherheit deiner Verschlüsselung so gut wie dein Passwort?
Das heißt, ich nehme nicht Mutti21?
Genau, weil das ist das, was zumindest nach meiner Kenntnis die Strafverfolgungsbehörden halt auch tun, dass sie tatsächlich versuchen, Passworte zu raten oder halt aus dem Umfeld irgendwie Passworte zu generieren. Sie versuchen natürlich auch technische Tricks und Kniffe anzuwenden, um halt zum Beispiel Passworte, die noch im Cache sind oder die auf die Platte geswapft wurden und andere Dinge mehr zu kriegen. Also man muss sich da halt schon Gedanken darüber machen, wie es halt funktioniert. Dass Verschlüsselung direkt im geheimnützlichen Sinne per kriptoanalytischen Attacke gebrochen wurde, ist mir zumindest aus dem Strafverfolgungsbereich nicht bekannt.
Ist mir auch noch nichts bekannt.
Also das ist ja auch gerade der Grund, wo wir auch ja letztes Mal bei Sönke noch mal drüber gesprochen haben, der Grund, warum diese Computer-Wanze, die ja auch Bundes-Trojaner oder Online-Durchsuchung genannt wird, etabliert werden soll. Weil genau an die verschlüsselten Daten, wenn die mit einem guten Passwort geschützt sind, eben kein Zugang möglich ist.
Also gute Verschlüsselung plus gutes Passwort. Allgemein kann man sagen, wenn die Geheimdienste Verschlüsselungen brechen können, erzählen sie niemandem, auch nicht den Strafverfahrensbehörden. Also das ist halt so, weil dann müssten sie zugeben, dass diese Verschlüsselung schwach ist. Das würde in einem Strafverfahren rauskommen, das würden sie halt niemals zugeben.
Also um das andere zu beantworten, Sebastian, die Verschlüsselung ist immer nur so gut A wie dein Passwort und B so gut, wie du dich selber gut fühlst dabei.
Okay, und alphanomenisch 20 Ziffern laufe ich gut, oder?
Wenn es hinhör ich, das klingt zufällig.
Wenn du dir die alle merken kannst?
Also ein guter Weg zum Beispiel, sowas zu tun, ist sich einen schönen langen Satz zu nehmen, den man sich merken kann und davon irgendwie, was ist sich den Anfangsbuchstaben, den dritten Buchstaben, den letzten Buchstaben, so ein paar Zahlenreinwürfe oder dergleichen Dinge.
Also ich kann das doch sehr gut mit reimen, also längere Reime, etwa so nett, das kann man sich dann noch sehr gut merken.
Und dann fällt dir leider die 538. Schrofe von der Glocke nicht ein und dann hast du ein Problem, da kommst du mit einem Passwort. Das ist kein so nett. Sebastian, ganz kurz zum Schluss an dich, die Frage, die mir gerade in den Kopf kommt. Wir reden so viel über diesen Bundes-Trojaner, über dieses Virus, was auf Computer raufgeht und der hat so viele Namen. Wollen wir dem nicht mal einen Namen geben?
Computer-Wanze.
Ach, Computer-Wanze ist so unsexy. Den kann man auch wie nennen? Den kann man Horst nennen oder Erwin oder Schnuffi oder so. Na ja, dann nennst du eben Schnuffi. Schnuffi heißt keiner. Gut, Sebastian, vielen Dank für den Anruf. 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz, wir reden heute darüber, wie konkret die Überwachung der Bürger mit ihren E-Mail-Kontakten, ihren, wie hast du das schon gesagt, Constanze, vorhin Fernmelde-Daten, heißt das so? Nee, wie heißt denn das? Telekommunikations-Fern-Dingst-Bolus?
Telekommunikations-Verbindungs-Daten.
Ja, wie sowas genau in der Praxis funktioniert. Wir haben heute schon einige Geschichten gehört, einige Fragen auch bekommen, wenn ihr die habt, könnt ihr die gerne stellen an uns. Die nächste Frage kommt von Roman aus Neukölln.
Ja, ich wollte auf den vorverletzten Anruf antworten, der wissen wollte, was er beachten muss, wenn er ins Internet geht.
Ja, genau, das war die Frage. Ich habe jetzt einen Rechner, der geht neu ans Netz, was soll ich machen?
Ja, ich würde ihm raten, als erstes TV in Kino Linux installieren, weil da kriegen die Klaglager euch, dass es unwahrscheinlicher ist, dass die da einen Bundesprojaner draufkriegen.
Das heißt, nicht die gängigen Betriebssysteme wie Mac OS oder Windows zu benutzen?
Auf jeden Fall würde ich ihn von Windows abraten, weil die da wahrscheinlich am meisten Einfallstüren haben. Das schließt aber noch nicht aus, also wenn er Linux nutzt, dann können die immer noch herausfinden, was bei ihm auf der Platte liegt, wenn sie eine Hausdurchsuchung, eine klassische Hausdurchsuchung mitnehmen. Dagegen hilft, wenn er sein verbotenes Video, was er hat, da frage ich mich, was das eigentlich sein könnte. Weil eigentlich sind ja nur Kinderbrotten verboten. Wenn er irgendwelche Kinderbrotten hat, die sollte er nur zum Anspielen, zum Abspielen unverschließend liegen lassen.
Moment, wir gehen jetzt mal nicht davon aus, dass irgendjemand, der hier anruft, so einen Scheiß auf der Platte hat. Also wollen wir mal kurz klarstellen.
Naja, ob das Scheiß ist oder nicht, darüber kann man sich streiten.
Darüber müssen wir glaube ich nicht streiten. Okay, also deine Anmerkung war in jedem Fall Linux anstatt von Mac OS und auf keinen Fall Windows.
Und verboten das Video mit PGG-Verschlüsseln und neben Dateinamen geben, der unverdächtig ist.
Guter Tipp. Wir haben jetzt schon sehr viel über so Geschichten gesprochen, wie das im Technischen funktioniert mit dem Bundestrojaner zum Beispiel, mit sonstigen Dingen der Überwachung. Die Frage, die immer noch nicht wirklich geklärt ist, ist, wie kriege ich das mit, dass ich möglicherweise im Beobachtungsfadenkreuz stehe.
Also wenn es jetzt nur um die Computerwanze geht, dann ist natürlich gerade das Ansinnen der Ermittlungsbehörden, dass man es nicht mitbekommt. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass diese handelsüblichen Firewalls oder Anti-Viren-Programme natürlich nicht gegen so eine individualisierte Spionage-Software helfen. Na klar. Aber wenn man jetzt den Fall von Martin sieht, wo man ja nicht nur diese eine Möglichkeit genommen hat, sondern einfach mal alles, was technisch ging, dann gibt es vielleicht schon Möglichkeiten. Da können wir vielleicht ja Martin mal direkt fragen. Hattest du vorab irgendwelche Ideen, dass dich vielleicht jemand abhören könnte oder kam es wirklich total aus der Kalt? Hast du mal jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet Anhaltspunkte dafür gesehen?
So verdächtige Schleitende in der Ecke oder irgendwie sowas?
Ich glaube, wenn man da nicht extrem hinterher ist und nun total paranoid, kriegt man das einfach nicht mit. Und dass jetzt jemand paranoid ist, heißt ja nicht, dass er nicht verfolgt wird.
Also du kannst sagen, du warst arglos, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen kann.
Das ist eine Suggestivfrage.
Auf jeden Fall bin ich von einer Hausdurchsuchung überrascht worden.
Also es ist ja vielleicht natürlich immer ein Wir-kennen-Fälle, wo mal was schiefgegangen ist, etwa bei der Abrechnung und der Übersendung von Rechnung von Telefonfirmen, sowas haben wir mal gehört. Es ist uns auch bekannt geworden, dass dann mal eben dadurch die Abhörmaßnahme bekannt geworden ist. Aber in der Regel ist natürlich der Sinn der Sache, dass man es nicht mitbekommt und in der Regel wird man es auch nicht mitbekommen. Immer erst dann, wenn es zu einem Verfahren kommt und ein Anwalt vielleicht irgendwie Einsicht nehmen kann, dann erfährt man es halt.
Nur ist diese Sendung nicht ganz, weil es gibt ja durchaus den Fall, dass sie wollen, dass du weißt, dass du überwacht wirst, um dir Panik zu machen, um dich einzuschüchtern oder sonst irgendwas noch zu machen.
Es gibt natürlich noch eine Sache, die man in dem Zusammenhang erwähnen muss. Die meisten, eigentlich alle dieser Bewachungsmaßnahmen sind per Gesetz mit einer nachträglichen Benachrichtigungspflicht versehen. Entsprechend müssten eigentlich die Ermittlungsbehörden diese Benachrichtigungen senden, aber praktisch und wir haben es auch gerade in einer wissenschaftlichen Studie wieder erfahren, wird das dann weniger als ein Drittel der Fälle überhaupt getan.
Das heißt, Martin hätte quasi drei Tage später einen Brief bekommen müssen, in dem drin stand, hallo, wir waren übrigens in deiner Wohnung.
Ne, so natürlich nicht. Das passiert dann erst, wenn das ganze Verfahren abgeschlossen ist und es gibt halt sehr viele Ausnahmen, die der Gesetzgeber da schon in die Gesetze reingeschrieben hat, weswegen sie eben nicht benachrichtigen, etwa wenn sie ein anderes Strafverfahren damit gefährden, wenn sie einen V-Mann aufdecken würden. Es sind immer eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten und das wird schlicht und nur weniger als ein Drittel der Fälle getan.
Gesetzgeber und Gesetze, kommt sofort unser Rechtsanwalt Sönke und meldet sich zu Wort.
Naja, vor allem, ich habe immer so einen Eindruck, dass diese nachträglichen Benachrichtigungen gar nicht dazu passieren, um den Betroffenen irgendwie noch nachträglich eine Chance zu geben, sich zur Wehr zu setzen oder sonst irgendwie die Interessen der Betroffenen noch irgendwie zu schützen oder zu berücksichtigen. Die Fälle von nachträglichen Mitteilungen, die mir so bekannt geworden sind, hatten vor allem katastrophale Folgen für die Betroffenen selber. Da sind nämlich nicht nur die Betroffenen benachrichtigt worden, sondern auch alle anderen Gesprächsteilnehmer. Das sind also dann die Situationen eingetreten, dass Leute, die sich überhaupt nicht zur Schulden kommen haben lassen, völlig unschuldig in ein Ermittlungsverfahren geraten sind, deren Telefonate sind abgehört worden. Das hat man ihnen dann nachher mitgeteilt, so weit, so grausam, aber immerhin, es gab die Mitteilung. Und wem hat man das noch alles mitgeteilt? Dem ganzen sozialen Umfeld, deren Telefonnummer man ja schließlich auch hat und deren Namen man zum Teil hatte. Und dann wusste das ganze soziale Umfeld, dass irgendeine schwere Straftat verfolgt wurde und dass man den Anschluss eben der Unschuldigen abgehört hat. Das ist also die Rufschädigung noch im Nachhinein trotz erwiesener Umschuld, die mit solchen Benachrichtigungen dann auch verbunden sein kann. Das Instrument geht also in diesen Fällen völlig nach hinten los und der gute Wille absolut in die Hose. Und den Betroffenen selber ist damit fast noch mehr geschadet, als wenn man sie über Auskunft betätigt.
Also hast du wirklich diesen Eindruck, weil wir haben so eine Diskussion mit Politikern, wenn halt dieses Thema angesprochen wird, immer den Eindruck, dass halt eher massiv vermieden wird, diese Mitteilung zu machen, um einfach das ganze Ausmaß dessen, wie viel überwacht wird, tatsächlich überhaupt nicht deutlich werden zu lassen?
Das stimmt schon, das wird massiv vermieden, aber in den Fällen, wo dann doch Informationen rausgehen, dann schaden sie den Betroffenen noch mehr. Natürlich ist es in der Sache völlig richtig, es werden nur eine Handvoll Prozent von geheimen Ermittlungsmaßnahmen tatsächlich den Betroffenen auch bekannt und dann naja in den meisten Fällen dann eher auch im Haftbefehl oder in der Anklageschrift, aber nicht dadurch, dass sie es nachher nochmal nachträglich trotz erwiesener Unschuld erfahren.
Sönke, wir hören jetzt genau zu was ich sage, nicht, dass ich Blödsinn erzähle, aber worüber wir heute in dieser Sendung reden, sind nicht irgendwie Straftaten, die wirklich passieren, die auch zu verfolgen sind und die zu ahnden sind, sondern wir reden darüber, dass Leute, die offensichtlich unschuldig sind bzw. mit einer bestimmten Sache nichts zu tun haben, durch Zufälle mit ins Raster der Observierung, der Überwachung reinrutschen und dann die Folgen damit zu tragen haben. Hab ich das richtig jetzt zugedreht? Dazu haben wir nämlich einen Anruf aus Schweinfurt aus Franken von Christoph. Hallo Christoph, guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend, hallo.
Grüße dich. Wir sind jetzt nämlich genau bei dem Punkt, wo ich glaube, dass du darüber reden möchtest, dass man kalte Füße bekommt bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Genau, ich habe einfach nur Angst. Ich habe einfach nur Angst. Es geht mir darum, dass ich jetzt nicht der Kriminelle bin oder der Typ, der irgendwas schwer wegen des Todes und Gottes will, mir geht es einfach nur, ich habe einfach nur Angst. Ich erfahre nicht, dass ich überwacht werde, dass ich abgehört werde. Es werden vielleicht auch Profite erstellt, man weiß es nicht. Meine Angst ist halt dahingehend, dass ich einfach nicht weiß. Ich werde meine persönlichen Freiheiten irgendwo eingeschränkt und ich habe einfach meine Angst, dass ich mein Leben nicht mehr selbstbestimmt irgendwann leben kann. Ich habe einfach die Angst, ich kann nicht entscheiden. Man kann sich dagegen auch schlecht werden, würde ich sagen, weil es entwickelt sich alles irgendwo hin. Man weiß es nicht, wozu es irgendwann gut sein wird.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite den Kopf einzuziehen und zu sagen, es wird alles sowieso irgendwann passieren und es ist alles schlimm, das ist ja auch nicht der Weg, den man gehen sollte.
Es ist nicht der Weg, ich sage irgendwann der Weg, wo jeder so… Was will man dagegen tun? Irgendwann hat sich so etwas entwickelt und keiner kann mehr was dagegen machen.
Na ja, dazu machen wir ja Sendungen wie diese, um zumindest über diese Vorgänge aufzuklären.
Also es ist natürlich nicht so, dass man nichts machen kann. Also den Kopf in den Sand stecken kann nicht die Antwort sein. Und wir haben ja gerade diesen Samstag in Berlin bei der Demo gesehen, dass wir eben nicht alleine sind, sondern wir waren da eben 10.000. Das heißt, man muss kommunizieren, dass einen diese Entwicklung hin zu einem Überwachungsstaat stört. Wir sind diejenigen, die die Volksvertreter wählen. Wir können uns auch an die wenden. Wir können uns politisch engagieren. Also wir vom Chaos Computer Club tun dies. Natürlich würde ich nicht behaupten, wir sind total toll erfolgreich und würden da viel erreichen, aber ich denke, dass nur, wenn wir hier einen Konsens herstellen, wenn die Mehrheit sagt, nein, wir wollen hier nicht so abgeschnorchelt werden, nur dann wird sich was ändern.
Da bin ich auch voll dahinter. Ich bin da auf jeden Fall einer, der voll dahinter steht, weil man will ja auch irgendwo tun lassen, was man möchte. Man möchte sein Leben in die eigene Hand nehmen.
Ja, du musst es schlicht artikulieren, und zwar überall. In deinem Freundeskreis, in deinem Familienkreis, in dem Webblog, was du vielleicht hast, und deinem Abgeordneten. Also das ist schlicht einfach, man muss es sagen. Wir leben schließlich immer noch an so weit in der Demokratie, dass wir es offen sagen dürfen.
Genau, ich habe schon bei mir eine Familie mit diskutiert, und mein Vater befasst sich da ja auch mit dem Thema. Der Vater ist mittlerweile schon 55, und der hat ja früher irgendwas zur Neu-Welt-Ordnung und irgendwas geredet, man weiß nie. Ich kriege da mittlerweile Angst, dass es ein Puzzle-Stein zu allem sein könnte. Und naja, man weiß nie, gell?
Im Zweifelsfall ist entweder eine Mail oder ein Brief an deinen lokalen Datenschutzbeauftragten oder aber deinen örtlichen Volksvertreter in Speinfurt schon ein Anfang, das du sagen kannst, das gefällt mir nicht. Alles klar. Danke für den Anruf, Christoph. Der nächste Anruf kommt wieder aus Berlin und zwar von Stefan. Guten Abend Stefan.
Guten Abend.
Grüße dich. Wir werden jetzt wieder ein bisschen detaillierter und reden über Mail-Systeme.
Ja genau, das ist eigentlich ein Thema, was mich sehr interessiert. Es ist ja doch sehr verbreitet, dass man Anbieter, sagen wir mal, wie Yahoo oder Ruhi oder was auch immer nutzt. Also ich sage jetzt mal speziell Yahoo und mich würde mal interessieren, wie das von den Extarten, die jetzt im Studio sitzen, was so eingeschätzt wird, wenn man also Yahoo benutzt, insbesondere jetzt vom E-Mails zu empfangen und um sie halt zu verschicken. Wie sicher ist das? Oder sind da Gefahren vorhanden? Ich habe zum Beispiel aktuell speziell, dass ich irgendwelche merkwürdigen Mails erhalte, wo es heißt, es wird nun Geld von meinem Konto abgebucht, die ich dann auch ignoriere. Aber ich kriege sehr viele komische Meals, teilweise auch irgendwelche Erotikangebote, wo ich gar nicht weiß, woher die kommen. Also das interessiert mich jetzt mal speziell, wie wird das so gesehen von den Fachleuten?
Das heißt, du kriegst einen Haufen Spam und willst wissen, warum?
Das habe ich jetzt akustisch nicht verstanden.
Du kriegst einen Haufen Spam, also ungewünschte Mails, du wirst zugemüllt mit Werbung und sonstigen Anfragen und weißt nicht warum und würdest gerne wissen, wo die herkommen?
Ja, das ist sicherlich ein Grund, sage ich mal, aber mich beschäftigt eigentlich mehr der Gedanke, wie gefährlich ist das, dass aufgrund so einer Mail praktisch mein System irgendwie gehackt wird, also praktisch, dass jemand in meine vorhandenen Mails, die ich bei Yahoo! drin habe, reingelangt, und dass ich das wünsche. Das ist mir eigentlich wichtiger. So eine Spam-Mail ist sicherlich nicht schön, aber die kann man dann auch löschen.
Okay, reden wir nicht über Spam und fragen wir am besten jemanden, der das absolut weiß, nämlich Frank vom CCC.
Eigentlich ist das nicht so richtig unser Thema heute hier. Der E-Mail ist halt ein riskantes Kommunikationsmedium. Wenn du irgendwie der Sicherheit deines Systems nicht hier sicher sein kannst, solltest du nicht auf unbekannte Anhänge klicken. Du kannst in jedem Fall davon ausgehen, dass die Strafverfolgungsbehörden genau kein Problem haben, die E-Mail bei Yahoo! oder wem auch immer darauf zuzugreifen. Und wenn dein Passwort bei Yahoo! nicht besonders sicher ist, dann im Zweifel auch irgendwie der Rest der Welt. Letztendlich ist die Nachricht, du musst dich halt darum kümmern, such dir halt einen ordentlichen E-Mail-Anbieter, der halt irgendwie...
Was wären ordentliche E-Mail-Anbieter?
E-Mail-Anbieter, die sich halt darum kümmern, dass sie ordentliche Spam-Filter haben und man halt eben nicht zugemüllte Postfläche hat. Und ein E-Mail-Client, der halt nicht irgendwie jedes Attachment automatisch aufmacht. Also zum Beispiel halt irgendwie Thunderbird benutzen anstatt Outlook Express.
Also Thunderbird statt Outlook Express und für einen E-Mail-Anbieter vielleicht noch einen Tipp, weil wir müssen sowieso Nachrichten machen.
Ja, such dir einen aus, gibt genügend die halt irgendwie...
Letzte Frage nochmal, besteht denn die Gefahr dann erst, wenn man den Anhang öffnet oder nur wenn man die E-Mail aufmacht?
Das hängt von deinem E-Mail-Client ab, wenn du halt irgendwie Outlook oder ähnliche verwendest, dann kann es halt auch passieren, dass das schon losgeht, wenn du nur die E-Mail aufmachst.
Also Augen auf und Mails zu.
Ich bedanke mich.
Danke Stefan, tschüss.
Schönen Abend.
Hallo und ich bin ein Trailersprecher. Und jetzt machen wir einen Trailer. Dein Konzert, richtig? Ab 19 Uhr in Fritzlub im Postbahnhof, direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof.
Mehr Infos fritz.de This is gonna get us high Okay, money brother, that's all.
You've been prima.
Und das hört man zwei nachher zwölf Uhr. Mit Liane Gruß.
Nachdem bei den Massenprotesten in Börmer mindestens acht Menschen von Sicherheitskräften erschossen worden, bereitet der UN-Sicherheitsrat auf einer Sondersitzung. Generalsekretär Bann kündigte die Entsendung seines Sonderbeauftragten an. Außerdem rief er die Militärregierung erneut zur Zurückhaltung gegenüber den friedlichen Demonstranten auf. Der Bundesgerichtshof hat ein Grundsatzurteil zum Unterhalt nach Scheidungen getroffen. Die Richter urteilten, dass der Besserverdienende nicht lebenslang für den früheren Partner sorgen muss. Mit dieser Entscheidung werden zeitlich befristete Unterhaltszahlungen erlaubt. Aber der wirtschaftlich schlechter gestellte, soll der Besserverdienende nicht lebenslang für den früheren Partner sorgen muss. Mit dieser Entscheidung werden zeitlich befristete Unterhaltszahlungen erlaubt. Aber der wirtschaftlich schlechter gestellte, sollte sich langfristig mit dem begnügen, was er selbst erwirtschafte. Die Bundesregierung hat vor den Risiken gefälschter Produkte gewarnt. Mittlerweile seien auch hierzulande nachgemacht und auch gefährliche Medikamente aufgetaucht, erklärte Bundesjustizministerin Zypries. Gesundheitsgefährdend ist häufig auch Kleidung, weil illegale Zusatzstoffe Allergien auslösen könnten. Zudem verursachten die gefälschten Waren massive wirtschaftliche Schäden. Zypries stellte heute ein neues Internetportal vor, wo sich Unternehmen und Verbraucher über Produktpiraterie informieren können. Zum Sport. Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft der Frauen steht im WM-Finale. Die Titelverteidigerinnen gewannen das Halbfinale gegen Norwegen mit 3 zu 0. Und in der Fußball-Bundesliga hat Energie Cottbus eine Niederlage einstecken müssen. Der Tabellenletzte verlor auswärts gegen den Tabellenersten Bayern München mit 0 zu 5. Die weiteren Ergebnisse. Nürnberg gegen Leverkusen 1 zu 2, Stuttgart-Bochum 1 zu 0, Frankfurt-Karsruhe 0 zu 1 und Bielefeld gegen Hannover 0 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Angermünde und Wittenberge 10 Grad, Potsdam 11 Grad, Frankfurt 12 Grad und Cottbus und Neuropin 13 Grad, ebenfalls in Berlin 13 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es meist wolkig. Im Süden Brandenburgs kann es etwas Regen geben. Die Temperaturen gehen runter auf 10 bis 8 Grad. Morgen soll es dann meist wolkig bleiben. Ab und zu kann es regnen bei 15 bis 18 Grad. Auf den Straßen ist alles ruhig. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBEB.
Und wann im Radio 101, 5? Dann fritz im Eisenhüttenstadt.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein Schauspieler, ich bin ein Schauspieler. Ich bin ein Schauspieler, ich bin ein Schauspieler. Ich bin ein Schauser, ich bin ein Schauser. Ich bin ein Schauser, ich bin ein Schauser. Dann ist bei uns Sönke Hilbrans, er ist Rechtsanwalt. Und dann ist bei uns auch noch Martin, der ganz am Anfang der Sendung die Geschichte erzählt hat, wie er einen Anruf bekam, dass bei ihm zu Hause eine Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt wird. Hintergrund war der, dass er Kontakt hatte mit Leuten, die wiederum sich über ganz obskure Geschichten möglicherweise, ich bin da sehr konjunktiv, verdächtig gemacht haben sollten. Und in der allgemeinen Überwachung war sein Name eben mit dabei. Und plötzlich stand das BKA bei ihm in der Wohnung und hat eine Hausdurchsuchung durchgeführt. Ihr seht, wir reden über Überwachung durch den Staat, wir reden über den Bundestrojaner, wir reden über E-Mail-Speicherung, Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die ganzen Geschichten. Und wenn ihr da Fragen habt, dann können wir die gerne klären. Eine ist gekommen per Mail und zwar von Martin, der sagt, gibt es eigentlich einen ausländischen Free-Mail-Anbieter außerhalb der EU, bei dem keine Verbindungsdaten gespeichert werden?
Frank? Also keiner, der mir wirklich bekannt ist, weil die großen Free-Mail-Anbieter sind alle in Staaten, in denen es vergleichbare Gesetze gibt. Also in den USA oder Kanada oder Skandinavien und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Also es gibt sicherlich ein paar kleinere, die etwas restriktiver vorgehen und sagen, wir wollen wirklich eine gerichtliche Anordnung haben und antworten nicht auf jedes Fax, aber da ändert sich die Lage auch fortlaufend. Da muss man halt einfach mal ein bisschen selber recherchieren.
Also Antwort ist eher ein Nein.
Nicht wirklich so.
Ein leicht rosanes Vielleicht.
Genau.
Martin Koffer, wir haben die Frage an dem Moment für dich hinreichend beantwortet. Frank hat da aber noch eine andere Geschichte, die er ansprechen wollte.
Ja genau, und zwar was der Volker früher erzählt, war diese Geschichte, dass ja eine große Menge von Überwachungsmaßnahmen angewendet wurden. Du erwähntest Kameras vom Haus, GPS und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Wurde das denn alles auf einmal angewendet oder haben die das so nach und nach gesteigert?
Antwort ich jetzt mal drauf. Nee, das ging nach und nach. Also die müssten alle drei Monate, mussten Bundesrichter diese Maßnahmen verlängern. Und der Ablauf war schon so, dass sie am Anfang erst mal für die ersten vier Beschuldigten alles geholt haben. Dann haben sie nach drei Monaten gemerkt, außer Kontakten unter den Beschuldigten und in Bezug auf Verfahren haben wir gar nichts rausgekriegt. Also brauchen wir mehr. Und dann wurde das sukzessive über das ganze Jahr immer wieder weiter gesteigert. Also immer mehr Kameras, immer mehr GPS-Verwandtungen. Irgendwann wurden die Telefonanschlüsse der Freundinnen mit dazu genommen.
Haben sie das irgendwie begründet?
Die Begründung lautet immer Stereotyp. Wir konnten hier wichtige Erkenntnisse gewinnen über Kontakte der Beschuldigten untereinander sowie über ihre politischen Tätigkeiten und so weiter. Also nichts, was im Bezug auf den Vorwurf eigentlich relevant wäre.
Im Zuge dessen kommt noch mal die Frage, die wir jetzt auch möglicherweise gleich am Telefon noch mal klären müssen, haben, die in der Sendung immer wieder auftaucht, kriegt man raus, dass man überwacht wird? Die ist heute schon so oft gefallen, aber Leute schalten rein und raus, deswegen vielleicht jetzt noch mal die Antwort dazu, bevor wir zum nächsten Anruf bekommen. Ja, wenn überhaupt, beziehungsweise wie ich vorhin schon sagte, wenn sie es wollen. Und die Frage ist, ob irgendjemand will, dass man dir mithält, dass du überwacht wirst. Also entweder aus Gründen, um dich einzuschüchtern oder quasi in der Erwartung, dass du verunsichert bist und dann nicht weißt, was du machen sollst und so weiter und so fort. Nur in unserem Verfahren ist es so, dass quasi diese Eskalationslawine, die die da nach und nach losgetreten haben, ja dazu geführt hat, dass, weil gegen die Leute nichts gefunden worden ist, sie sich jetzt auch wieder verdächtig machen.
Ich meine, es gibt noch so eine Art taktische Aufklärung, dass also dann über Presseorgane, ja über bestimmte Presseorgane, dann rauskommt, dass es in einem bestimmten Zusammenhang irgendwo ein Verfahren und Überwachung gibt. Und das kann man sich vielleicht auch vorstellen als eine wirklich taktische Maßnahme. Dann mal gucken, was dann passiert, welche, wie die Szene darauf reagiert, wie die Leute darauf reagieren, die man direkt angesprochen hat, und daraus dann vielleicht Lüste zu ziehen.
Das heißt also, die publizieren irgendwo ein Artikel, Munkel, Munkel, da gibt es irgendein Verfahren, böser Terrorismus, und dann guckt man, wie er irgendwie hektisch anfängt, nicht mehr zu telefonieren?
Jedenfalls wundert man sich manchmal, wie so bestimmte eigentlich streng geheime Ermittlungen von meiner Zeitung stehen.
Ach, verstehe.
0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer vom Plumun, vom heutigen Chaosradio, Teil 128. Angerufen hat René aus Löwenberg. Hallo René, guten Abend.
Hallo.
Du hast jetzt sehr lange warten müssen. Ich hoffe, du kannst das verschmerzen, weil du hast ja gehört, was hier hier los war.
Also ich bin auf jeden Fall dafür, dass die Leute mehr überwacht werden sollten.
Aha, wieso das denn?
Weil immer noch zu viel passiert. Also mir ist es egal, ob ich bei Aral abwischt werde wie drei Bierkurve oder zwei Schachten Gippen oder fünf Liter Tanker. Ist doch egal. Jeder, der nichts zu verbergen hat, der hat auf jeden Fall gar keine Probleme. Und ich hör immer nur, dass die Leute damit ein Problem haben, dass sie überwacht werden. Warum denn?
Na ja, du hast doch schon mitbekommen, dass zum Beispiel der Anrufer vorhin halt nicht mehr genau weiß, ob er noch irgendwie mit jemandem telefonieren kann, weil er einfach nicht weiß, wem zuhört. Wir hatten hier gerade von Martin gehört, dass offensichtlich die Polizei tatsächlich ein bisschen geschlafen hat, hineinbeobachtet hat. Möchtest du das?
Na, also es ist mir doch egal, weil ich begehe ja keine Straftate, wenn ich telefoniere oder im Internet bin. Es ist mir doch selber egal.
Im Endeffekt ist das, was René jetzt sagt, durchaus ein gewichtiges Argument. Jeder muss für sich selber entscheiden, wie er mit der ganzen Geschichte umgeht und wie man dazu steht. Und wenn du sagst, mir ist egal, dann ist das eine vollkommen freie Entscheidung von dir, die du im Zweifelsfall vor dir selber rechtfertigen musst.
Du ist schon richtig, aber ich spreche hier den Gag mal für viele, weil... Warum, warum, ist doch egal, ob jeder weiß, dass ich einen Dreißigstab bei Shell kaufe oder ob ich hier fünf Kilo Schwatt bei allem ankaufe, ist doch egal.
Vielleicht, du hast ja die Geschichte mitbekommen von Martin, die hier erzählt wurde. Und jetzt mal Hand aufs Herz, könntest du dir vorstellen, dass dich so was treffen würde? Aber dann findest du trotzdem keine Unangenehme?
Nein, weil ich habe nichts zu verbergen.
Du sagst, sie könnten dein Haus ruhig durchsuchen und dir eine GPS-Wanze ans Telefon machen, dein Schlafzimmer abhören, dein Telefon abhören, deine E-Mails lesen und du hättest da kein Unangenehmes Gefühl.
Nein, überhaupt gar nicht, weil ich habe meinen Sex so wie jeder anderen hat oder auch nicht. Aber es ist egal.
René, ich bin ganz ehrlich, ich bin froh, dass du angerufen hast und auch diese andere Seite der Diskussion hier in diese Sendung reingetragen hast, denn um es normal zu sagen, die Entscheidung, wie man dazu steht, liegt eindeutig bei einem selber und wenn du das so siehst, dann... Genau, alles klar. Danke dir für deinen Anruf. Dir auch, tschüss. Der nächste am Telefon ist Sven aus Lichtenberg. Hallo Sven. Grüße dich. Was hältst du denn von der Sache, die René gerade erzählt hat, dass es einem egal ist? Also diese klassische... Ich hab ja nichts zu befürchten.
Also ich habe mir sehr oft und sehr lange darüber Gedanken gemacht. Ich habe dieses auch nachgeforscht und habe sehr bedenkliche Ergebnisse herausgefunden.
Was hast du nachgeforscht?
Na, wie zum Beispiel ein Verkäufer, den ich mal mir was gekauft habe, mich über Internet anschreiben kann und mir genau das anbietet, was ich genau brauche. Dann habe ich mir mal Gedanken gemacht, wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Es ist egal, was du benutzt, ob es deine EC-Karte ist, ob es irgendwelche Playback-Punkte sind, darüber werden Daten gespeichert.
Playback-Punkte gefällt mir übrigens auch sehr.
Ja, das ist zarkastisch, aber es ist wirklich schlimm. Einige Leute wissen nicht, was sie damit anrichten. Ob du dir hier eine Zeitung abonnierst, da hast du schon verloren. Weil sie wissen genau, was sind deine Interessen, was für Bücher liest du. Wenn du Bücher aus dem Internet holst, was für Bücher interessiert dich. Und in dem Moment kriegst du Post, in dem Moment kriegst du Information, du wirst eingeschätzt, du wirst eingeschätzt, was interessiert dich, für was willst du zu haben. Es ist doch schlimm zu wissen, dass man so kontrolliert wird.
Was nicht nur damit passiert, was du an Post bekommst und für was dich interessiert, was auch noch nicht angesprochen wurde, sind solche Geschichten, dass man ein Profil erstellt von der Gegend, in dem du wohnst. Wenn in deiner Straße zum Beispiel 20 Leute bei Quelle, Otto, wo auch immer, irgendwas bestellen und von den 20 Leuten bezahlen, 18 nicht pünktlich, dann kriegst du in deiner Straße ein Häkchen in dein Profil rein, in dem drin steht, René zahlt bitte per Vorkasse.
Das würde mich nicht stören. Was aber schlimm ist, ist, dass es Dealer gibt, die deine Informationen verkaufen, die dadurch noch Geld machen. Und das kann es nicht sein. Ich werde sozusagen protokolliert, auf diese Art und Weise, im Grunde genommen, ich weiß nicht, ob der Film Staatsfeind Nummer 1 bekannt ist. Man könnte sich dadurch nur schützen, indem man in einem Käfig leben würde, der komplett von der Außenwelt abgeschottet ist. Indem man keine EC-Karten benutzt, keine Handys, die per Vertrag laufen, sondern Prepaid-Karten. Das wäre aber auch schon anzapfbar, da Handys auf dem Markt schwarz kaufen sind, die zu präparieren sind. Das heißt, du kannst überall ausgetauscht werden.
Hör mal Luft, ganz kurz, bevor du mir da Hyperventilien umkippst. Die von dir eben konstruierte Situation, das wäre aber ein ganz schön langweiliges Leben, wenn man da in seiner kleinen Kiste wohnt und mit keinem telefoniert.
Das ist richtig. Ich sage mal so, wenn ich mir so meinen Vorgänger angehört habe, der mir angeblich erzählen möchte, er ist sauber. Also das ist ja wie, als wenn er mir erzählen würde, er hat in seinem Leben noch nie gelügt. Das wäre die größte Lüge seines Lebens. Also kein Mensch ist perfekt, kein Mensch macht keine Fehler. Und es gibt Fehler, die man macht und die man angeblich, am liebsten nicht gerne an die Großglocke gehangen haben möchte. Und wenn ich mir so überlege und mir so angehört habe in der Sendung, ich höre eure Sendung übrigens jedes Mal, es gibt keine Sendung, die ich nicht gehört habe.
Oh, danke.
Es ist absolut Hammer, ihr habt Themen, da bin ich...
Okay, pass auf, da uns die Zeit wegläuft, lass uns mal diese, wir schenken uns gegenseitig Blumen und backen uns einen Kuchengeschicht in eine andere Mama.
Ja, die haben wir ja auch gehabt. Ein Kollege von mir, den haben sie hops genommen, auf gut Deutsch. Ja, und warum? Weil er für einen Kollegen eine CD kopiert hat und sozusagen der Kollege wurde überprüft und wurde, wie der Kollege hier im Studio, beschattet. Und dadurch, dass er ja Kontakt mit ihm hatte, war er genauso verdächtig wie alle anderen. Und das kann es nicht sein, dass man, weil man eine Kleinigkeit kopiert hat, gleich als Straftäter betitelt wird. Da gibt es andere Sachen, ja, wie Kinderschänder oder so, um die sie sich kümmern sollten. So eine Leute sollten sie abhören, so eine Leute sollten sie überprüfen. Den Leuten gehören eigentlich die Pfoten abgehackt. Ja, wenn ich mir gucke, dass Kinder, Pädophile, die aus dem Internetdaten ziehen, vier Jahre kriegen und Leute, die Kinder missbrauchen, beiher oder ein...
Sven, pass auf, wir machen jetzt genau wieder Folgendes, was wir eben schon mal gemacht haben, hol mal Luft. Also für deine Meinung vielen Dank, aber ich denke, wir sollten auch das, was René eben gesagt hat, der sagte, mir ist es doch egal, können sie machen, so eine Meinung muss man respektieren. Wenn jemand sagt, mir ist es egal, ich hab mir nichts zu Schulden kommen lassen, sollen sie doch kommen, dann muss man sagen, okay, wenn du so dazu stehst, bitteschön, es ist deine freie Entscheidung.
Aber unterstützt in ihrer Meinung, kann es nicht sein. Der kleine Bürger hat genauso das Recht, sich zu wehren. Und wenn nur eine Stimme sagt, nein, ich möchte das nicht, dann haben sie das zu akzeptieren.
Punkt, warte mal, haben sie das zu akzeptieren? Punkt, weil wir eigentlich nur noch 5 Minuten Zeit haben, weil Martin Petersdorf steht vor der Tür und die Telefonleistung Eick fliegt mir um die Ohren.
Alles klar, dann möchte ich nur noch letzten Satz sagen, Shit Happens, auf gut Deutsch.
Ich brauche jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr sagen, dass ihr noch anrufen könnt, weil wir schaffen sowieso eigentlich schaffen wir nur noch einen Anrufer. Alle anderen möchte ich bitten, also A, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ihr könnt weiter über diese Sendung diskutieren, entweder im Fritzboard, auf fritz.de oder eure Fragen direkt stellen an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und das letzte Thema, was wir heute aufmachen, dann ist dann auf jeden Fall auch nochmal Sönke bei uns, nämlich unser Anwalt, kommt von Markus aus Leipzig.
Guten Abend.
Grüße dich.
Soll ich gleich anfangen? Also ich rufe an, weil ich noch was beisteuern wollte, und zwar, wir hatten drüber gesprochen, 129A, Bildung einer terroristischen Vereinigung, Sprengstoffanschläge, Mord und Totschläge und so weiter, aber da gibt es auch noch andere Themen. Seit zwei Monaten gibt es die sogenannten Hackerparagrafen, 202A bis C und 303A bis B im Strafgesetzbuch, die halt Computersabortage, Datenveränderungen, Ausspielung von Daten unter Strafe stellen, und der 303B, Computersabortage und auch die Folgeparagrafen werden eben auch in 129A mitgenannt. Also sprich, da gibt es halt auch für die Behörden ganz neue Möglichkeiten, terroristische Vereinigungen sich bilden zu lassen, sage ich mal. Denn was man ja auch sagen muss ist, der 129A noch nie dazu geführt, dass jemand verurteilt worden ist, meines Wissens nach, sondern das enthalten seine Ermittlungsparagrafen.
Das ist jetzt sehr, sehr viel internes Fachchinesisch.
Also de facto, worum es da geht, ist das mit der Verschärfung der Computerkriminalitätsparagrafen ist de facto Hacking auch, also beziehungsweise Hacking im negativen Fall, also Angriff auf Computer und Computersabortage, zu einer sogenannten Katalogstraftat geworden. Das heißt also, wenn man sich dazu verabredet, dieses zu tun, dann kann man auch als terroristische Vereinigung betrachtet werden mit irgendwie all den Folgen, die wir heute hier schon ausführlich erläutert bekommen haben. Ja, also ist halt wieder mal eine weitere Verschärfung der Sachlage.
Der CCC ist damals quasi direkt betroffen, denn wir sind natürlich eine Vereinigung, die durch den Paragrafen in gewisser Weise bedroht wird. Und auch einige von den deutschen IT-Security-Firmen haben sich da doch sehr entsetzt gezeigt. Und es gibt auch schon Firmen, die ihr Geschäft ins Ausland verlagert haben, weil sie unter diesen Umständen hier auch nicht mehr arbeiten wollen.
Also danke nochmal für den Hinweis.
Welche Resonanzen gibt es da sozusagen von der Gesetzgeberseite auf diese ganzen kritischen Anmerkungen?
Also die Gesetzgeberseite ist, was jetzt die Abgeordneten betrifft, ist klar anzusehen, dass es sich dabei um Internet-Ausdrucke handelt. Es sind Leute, die ihre Computer nicht selber bedienen. Die haben ein explizites Verständnis vom Internet und von technischen Zusammenhängen, was sie aus Spielfilmen haben. Das merkt man auch immer wieder an Details. Die Beratungs-Assistenz ist extrem hoch. Da wird in der Regel nicht zur Kenntnis genommen, wenn alle Experten sagen, bitte macht das nicht so, das führt in die Katastrophe. Dann machen sie es erst recht so. Das sind unsere Erfahrungen aus der Lobbyarbeit, was diese Hacker-Paragraphen-Geschichte betrifft. Wir waren maßlos frustriert, wie stark da die Realitätszahne ist.
Man muss natürlich sehen, dass dieser Paragraph 202c seinen normalen Weg durch den Gesetzgebungsprozess genommen hat. Entsprechend gab es auch Anhörungen, etwa im Rechtsausschuss. Der CCC hat da Stellung genommen. Aber nicht nur wir, sondern auch die Wirtschaft hat Stellung genommen. Die Juristen haben Stellung genommen und die entsprechenden Verbände. Es gab eigentlich keine guten Gründe dafür. Dennoch hat eine große Mehrheit im Parlament dafür die Hand gehoben. Obwohl sich die Sachverständigen im Rechtsausschuss die Finger wundeschrieben haben und sich da auch eingefunden haben und ihre Sachverständigen Meinung da kundgetan haben. Es hat trotzdem nichts genutzt. Sie haben die Hand gehoben.
Warte mal, erstmal müssen wir sagen Danke, Markus. Und einen schönen Abend nach Leipzig. Bevor wir auf diese Veranstaltung hinweisen, würde ich gerne noch mal zwei grundsätzliche Fragen klären wollen, die in dieser Sendung ganz oft vorgekommen sind, aber die immer wieder auftauchen. Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, dass Überwachung durch die Sicherheitsbehörden in diesem Staat nicht nur eine angedachte Geschichte ist, sondern sehr real passiert. Wir haben viele Geschichten gehört, die ihr erlebt habt. Frage Nummer eins, wie kriege ich mit, dass so etwas läuft, gegenüber mich, über mich mit mir?
Nicht?
Gar nicht.
Was ist denn denn, Sie wollen es?
Frage Nummer zwei, was kann ich machen?
Naja, wenn man es halt mitkriegt, irgendwie zum Anwalt gehen. Das ist wahrscheinlich der einzige Rat, den man da irgendwie gut geben kann.
Ja, ich denke der Fall von Martin ist fast schon der Beleg dafür, dass man eigentlich vernünftig nichts machen kann. So blöde wie es kommen kann, können wir als Bürgerinnen und Bürger gar nicht vorausdenken. Und auch, das betrifft ja euch vom CCC, gerade auch seit der 309b im 129a drin ist. Also seit ein Hackerverein, eine terroristische Vereinigung sein können. Ihr könnt so viel Hackerethik haben, wie ihr wollt. Ihr wisst nicht, wie die Behörden das bewerten. Und ihr könnt auch heute nicht in die Herzen der Richter schauen, die eines Tages darüber entscheiden müssen. Ihr steht hier mit einem Bein, ich will nicht sagen im Gefängnis, aber mit einem Bein doch in einem Problem. Und könnt selber mit euch abmachen, wollt eure Freiheit gebrauchen, wollt ihr hacken, wollt ihr programmieren, wollt ihr eure Hacker-Agek pflegen oder wollt ihr sozusagen im Voraus einen Gehorsamen euch einen Kopf drüber machen, was gönnt ein Staatsanwalt davon haben?
Ja gut, also die Antwort ist halt ganz klar, wir stecken halt nicht den Kopf in den Sand. Weil wir haben ernsthaft erwogen, ob Auswahl eine Option wäre. Und wir haben uns dafür entschieden, doch lieber hierzu bleiben und zu kämpfen.
Also da muss man vielleicht noch mal eine Sache anmerken, weil ja vorhin auch noch mal die Sprache darauf kam, dass etwa die Benutzung von Privacy Enhancing Tools, also etwa Verschlüsselung oder dergleichen, einen besonders verdächtig macht. Ich würde halt ungern diese Message stehen lassen. Uns geht es eigentlich darum zu sagen, wenn viel mehr Leute ihre Privatsphäre mit Verschlüsselung nutzen würden und eben nicht alle E-Mails und Verschlüsselung und alle Chats und vielleicht auch mehr Anonymisierungssoftware benutzen würden, dann würde man da auch nicht so auffallen. Also wir hoffen halt nicht, dass gerade solche Berichte, wie sie Martin hier abgeliefert haben, dazu führen, dass du sagen würdest, ich benutze lieber gar keine Verschlüsselung, dann könnt ihr gerne ins Verhandlungsraster fahren. Das ist gerade nicht die Message, die wir bringen wollen, sondern wir wollen sagen, benutzt diese Tools.
Wir haben noch, jetzt kam das Ding mit dem Veranstaltungshinweis und dann würde ich gerne noch ein Schlusswort sagen. Ja genau, wir haben ja heute schon ein paar Sachen sprechen können, aber wir haben jetzt für den kommenden Sonntag um 11 Uhr, also eine Martinä in der Volksbühne am Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz in Berlin eine große Veranstaltung geplant, wo unter anderem über diesen Fall hier auch berichtet wird, aber wo auch noch mal die Möglichkeit besteht, zum 129a noch mal Fragen zu stellen. Es wird einen anderen Fall geben, wo noch jemand mal beschreibt, dem jetzt schon mehrfach passiert ist mit dem 129a, wie es ihm ergangen ist. Und es wird noch mal einen Bericht dazu geben, warum es notwendig ist, weiter sich auch zu organisieren, sich politisch zu wehren und nicht nur Abgeordnete anzuschreiben oder mit denen zu telefonieren, sondern auch selber was auf die Beine zu stellen. Kostas Eintritt? Muss man ja nur mal ganz kurz fragen. Also, das war's Chaosradio Teil 128 zum Thema Überwachung ganz real. Vielen Dank für eure ganzen Anrufe. Ich kann nicht lesen, was du mir da hingeschrieben hast.
Na, wir wollten noch auf die Sendung trackbacken, die Show mit Spereblick.
Ich wollte erst mal sagen, vielen Dank für eure Anrufe. Wenn man das zusammenfassen kann, was heute passiert ist, sind die Reaktionen auf diese ganzen Geschichten und Erlebnisse. Das macht mir Angst und ich weiß nicht, wie ich damit umgehen kann. Bis hin zu, ist mir doch egal, sollen sie doch einfach kommen. Ich denke, was wir alle mitnehmen können, ist, dass es wichtig ist, darüber einfach mal zu reden, sich darüber zu informieren und im Zweifelsfall anderen Leuten zu sagen, ich habe da ein komisches Gefühl, um einfach sich irgendwo mitzuteilen, um das weiter in die Welt zu tragen. Weiterhin möchte ich hinweisen, dass es auf Fritz nicht nur das Chaosradio gibt, sondern auch eine schöne Sendung namens trackback. Das läuft jeden Samstag von 18 Uhr bis 20 Uhr. Auf trackback geht es an diesem Samstag um Biometrie und um den neu einzuführenden E-Pass. Damit vielen Dank an den Chaos Computer Club, an Konstanze und an Frank. Vielen Dank an Martin für deine Geschichte. Vielen Dank an Sönke und vielen Dank an Volker. Euch einen schönen Abend. Wir gehen jetzt weiter mit Martin Petersdorf im Night Flight. Ich bin schon mal da.